[Music]
i
define myself as a cyborg because um i
am a cybernetic organism biologically i
am merged with technology or with
cybernetics
but also because i feel that technology
is part of my identity
so i i feel that i am technology so
i am psychologically united to
cybernetics and also biologically united
to cybernetics so
i identify as a cybernetic organism
how would it feel to control objects
with your mind or hear
colors or maybe even
live forever well if you want to find
out
all you have to do is become a cyborg
how would being part machine affect us
would it cause a greater divide between
the rich and the poor
and is this the next step in human
evolution
[Music]
this is what if wait to
call this a what if is a bit misleading
it's more of a when if because cyborgs
are already among us and according to
the world's first cyborg
neil harbison they're not going anywhere
we'll be able to decide which organs or
senses we
want to have as a species and then
whenever
someone that has modified him or herself
uh decides to have children then we
might see the birth
of uh babies with the organs or senses
that
their parents had so i'm sure we are
at the very critical moment in this
century where we'll start seeing this
happening it's already happening by
merging with technology but
whenever we do this biologically it will
be a much stronger change
and that's not the only change we can
expect with this technology
artificial intelligence is becoming more
advanced by the day
within the next 50 years ai will be
replacing
most of our jobs they'll simply be
better at them than we are
elon musk thinks that for humans to
avoid being reduced to the
usefulness of a house cat we'll need to
augment ourselves to compete with robots
although according to our resident
cyborg neil
instead of fighting the inevitable robot
takeover
we should embrace it but before we get
to that
let's start making you a cyborg
[Music]
the first decision you'll need to make
is what kind of changes
do you want to make to your body do you
want cybernetic eyes
that allow you to see in black and white
or sepia
what about a chip in your hand that
starts your car for you
or if you want to get crazy you could
change your entire bone structure to be
carbon fiber
the possibilities are practically
endless
when neil harbison decided to become a
cyborg
he wanted to view the world in a way it
had never been seen before
well i have an antenna implanted in my
head that allows me to extend my
perception of color
so the antenna allows me to sense from
infrareds to ultraviolets
the vibrations of color enter the
antenna and then the vibration of the
color goes
inside my skull so i feel color i feel
the vibrations of color
not only the visual spectrum but the
infrareds and ultraviolets
then there's also internet connections
so i can also receive
colors from other parts of the world so
there's people that can send colors to
my head
or i can connect to nasa's international
space station and then i can send
scholars from space
so the new oregon has internet
connection which i
use to extend my perception beyond my
body
human augmentation will allow us to be
better at almost
anything that we do now both physically
and mentally imagine having mechanical
arms
you'd be shooting three pointers more
consistently than steph curry
you'd have a harder punch than mike
tyson and a faster serve than serena
williams
that's because your arms will be
programmed to be more consistent
and just overall better than human
components could ever be
with two bionic arms you'd be one of the
greatest athletes
ever to live although if
everyone had these arms sports might be
more
boring but don't forget these arms can
be used for several things
most importantly they may help us
outwork robots in factories and other
lines of work
many of us are afraid of the inevitable
takeover of artificial intelligence but
maybe we're just watching too many
science fiction movies
um i don't think we should be scared of
ai
i mean if if i ever becomes more
intelligent than
humans the most intelligent thing will
be that they will
probably hey i will probably ignore us
it won't
either many people are scared that a i
will kill us
killing us is something very human so
killing humans
is something that we already do so that
wouldn't be more intelligent than
than humans so if ai ever becomes more
intelligent than
humans i don't think they'll it will be
dangerous
if you really want to see how this whole
rise of the machines thing will play out
maybe you can modify yourself to become
immortal
if you have a failing body part you
could simply replace it with a
mechanical one
and after it fails you could replace it
again and again
extending your life far past its natural
expiry date
but at this point you may barely be
human
the only organic part of you that might
remain could be your mind
is it too late to go back unfortunately
it is
once you become a cyborg there's no
turning back
even if you don't get any invasive
surgery
let's say you get an ear enhancement
that allows you to hear
as well as a bat if it somehow got
damaged or
fell out of your ear you wouldn't be
able to hear it all
why because your brain would have
adapted to hearing with your enhancement
once it's gone you wouldn't know how to
hear without it
oh and don't forget about the chance of
your body parts being
hacked and then losing control of them
not only that but who will be able to
get these enhancements
some people fear that they would only go
to the rich
causing further class divide in our
society
but what if it's the complete opposite
many people say that rich people will
become star wars but
it's not happening it's the poor people
that are becoming cyborgs everyone that
i know that has merged with technology
is not rich they are
students or they like myself i i did
i had no money i did it with with
friends and
really i'm not if you look at rich
people are not cyborgs
uh at least i don't know i can't think
of anyone
rich becoming a sideways it's people who
are not afraid of merging with
technology
that are becoming cyborgs and that has
nothing to do with
money you can become a cyborg for with
20
and 20 cents you can create a infrared
with a bit of
um with a motor and this you can install
it at the back of your head and then
you'll have
retrosection you can sense what's behind
you it's not
a thing about money to gain a sense i
think
in most cases you can also have chips
that
your cat or dog has you can have it
implanted and it's not
it's not it's not about money at least
now
instead of focusing on the potential
negative consequences of becoming
cyborgs
maybe we should start looking on the
bright side as
neil harbison explains cybernetic
modifications
could help us save the planet
[Music]
what we now call diversity has nothing
to do with the diversity we will see in
society
in the next few decades so we will see a
diversity of
species so we will be able to decide
which organs and senses we want to have
and this will create
a diversity uh that
we uh we have never experienced so
you'll meet people with organs and
senses that have nothing to do with
yours
and they'll have perception of reality
that is different from yours
but i think that's a thing that we
should all start focusing on we need
to start changing ourselves instead of
changing the planet we've been a species
that for thousands of years
have been changing the planet and
designing the planet in order to live
better and this hasn't
been any good we've been destroying the
planet this way
instead of creating light bulbs we
should have focused
in creating night vision so that we
don't spend so much energy creating
artificial light
or if we could control our own
temperature and find a way of
controlling our own temperature
instead of creating heaters and air
conditionings this would be much better
for the planet we wouldn't change the
temperature
of the planet we would change our own
temperature so we need we need to focus
on designing ourselves if we want to
continue
living in the planet without destroying
it and also whenever we do this
we'll be able to to also live better
because
we have not been able to adapt ourselves
in our own planet so i think
we need to start focusing on designing
ourselves
now if we really want to reduce our
impact on the planet
why don't we leave our bodies behind and
upload our brains to the cloud
well because that sounds like a story
for another what if